I don't have faith necessarily in Dave
Roberts I'm sorry hey look he got him
here but some of those decisions in
Boston confused me joining us how to
talk to World Series Game three from Fox
and MLB Network is JP Morosi who joins
us now on the line on the Rich Eisen
show am I going over the top a little
bit too much on Dave Roberts am I being
too harsh
well Andrew afternoon I would say this
that Dave Roberts is managing the team
now about the same way that he has
managed them all season long and he's of
course running up against a very very
good competition right now which is part
of the reason why his team is down o2
and really I had less of an issue with
the game one decision on the right left
matchup and bringing in Alex wood there
that then most did however I'll make
this big picture point that you've added
to the World Series and Cody Bellinger
was your NLCS MVP as a young player is a
big part of your team's future and he
does not start either of the first two
games of the World Series I realized
that that they were opposing a
left-handed pitcher both those games but
I think Andrew to some extent I agree
with you in the in the way that you've
got to put your best team on the field
within reason and I think sometimes when
you do things a little bit too
by-the-book
I think it maybe stifles your team a
little bit and I think the ballpark
atmosphere at Fenway Park the weather a
lot of those other factors I think we're
working against the Dodgers there but it
did not seem to me that it was a
free-flowing team that they had bats
were all that relaxed and and in rhythm
in the same way that Boston's were and I
have to think that some more involvement
from your best player in the previous
series might help that all right I'm not
suggesting that he doesn't have Dave
Roberts doesn't have autonomy here and
the right to make his own decisions but
these lineup decisions are they
organizational decisions or is he making
them alone while sitting on the plane
flying to Boston I think organizational
is probably the right word to use there
Andrew I think that it's too
this is the way that modern
organizations view the managers role I
grew up in the game I think back to my
first years covering baseball almost a
decade and a half ago and that the
managers seem to be these all-knowing
people with decades of experience in the
game which certainly Dave Roberts has as
well but that they they were left to
their own devices in terms of lineup and
their in-game decisions and now managers
are looked upon as being part of an
overall collective which is okay and
that's perfectly fine as as the job is
evolved but it does create a little bit
of a inconsistency publicly at least
when when it's Dave Roberts left to
explain for the losses at the podium
when in fact the decisions that went
into it were probably shared by many
many people
I think the Dodgers are probably Andrew
like a lot of teams in that there are
recommendations made from their
analytics departments to the manager
regarding lineups and and and there's
probably a sliding scale of all MLB
teams on how strictly those
recommendations are followed I I'm
pretty sure that the Dodgers would still
say and David still said that he has the
final say-so on the lineup car which i
think is true it's just a matter of how
much how much influencing there is going
on from from the front office and from
the analytics folks and I think in the
Dodgers case there's a fair amount of it
it still ultimately is David's decision
but there's a lot of influence there and
I think that's not that's not at all a
rarity for the game right now in the way
that it's played talking to JP Morosi or
from Fox and MLB Network on the JD
Martinez front what do we know about the
injury and if so cuz of no D H now at
Dodger Stadium where does he go tonight
if he plays well that's a great question
there's really been no definitive word
made yet here of course about seven
hours or so before first pitch so don't
people I'm sure pretty guarded about
things until we get a little bit closer
but he certainly to me is watching run
down the first base line Andrew and in
Game two looked it looked to me like
he's still being affected by that from
the slide the awkward slide in Game one
if he can't go then he's basically
relegated to a bit of a pinch-hitting
duty because you're not going to have
him in for defense late in the game
anyway and the tough part about in
limiting him
air is in the NL Park if you don't trust
him to get in the field then anytime you
go to him it's a to move move because
you have to have somebody coming in or
always going to hit for the pitcher and
then if the pitcher comes behind them
but no matter what you cannot have him
hit for a position player and then not
basically switch that person out with
either another position player or double
switching so there's to me it's a really
difficult method to use a position
player who's who's not feeling well
physically because you're worried about
him getting in the field so I I think if
he if he can start maybe maybe get him
an at-bat
early in the game and try to steal
abandon that bad of course so he'll be
able to hit on the road to be back to
the first inning before he even takes
the field which maybe lends its own
creative interpretations maybe in the
option therefore Alex Cora so I think if
he can couldn't have an at-bat don't
have them start maybe getting that
batter to in there but we have seen many
many times and ruin years past I think
back to Vladimir Guerrero playing for
the Rangers at San Francisco eight years
ago now you put those American League
the ages in the outfield and the ball
seems to have a radar and it finds them
in about the second inning so I think
that's something for the Red Sox to
consider it's fascinating I was watching
Alex Corps give an interview and ESPN
Deportes yesterday and I didn't I think
my high school Spanish served me well
enough where he said that he is gonna
play he just can't say yet where it's
going to be but JP the idea that he
would put him in there getting that bad
and then pull him is fascinating you
think that's a legitimate possibility I
think it's probably pretty far down the
list but options I would think maybe he
at least gets two at-bats and and and
one thing to watch and ruin in terms of
one where they bat him maybe they bump
them up a little bit even higher in the
lineup maybe there's a spot just to get
him the extra at-bat if they can and
then get him out of there for defensive
purposes it's always that middle game
push and pull up it's the fourth or
fifth inning you know let's say you've
got a one-run lead and he just had his
second or third at-bat you probably get
him out of the game now I think that's
got to be the mentality if in fact you
do it that way knowing of course that
you've got an elite defensive outfield
behind them with Jackie Bradley jr. in
center field and probably mookie betts
moving back to right so I think that's
or you can put Mookie a second we'll see
how that ends up playing out as well so
there's a lot
different things to think of I saw
mookie betts a and it'll be network
after game to that he's he's a little
nervous about playing second base the
ball ball comes that's pretty fast it's
been obviously number of years as Mookie
played a second base on a regular basis
so I think those are all things to
consider but I would say Andrew if JD
starts its what the idea that I think he
gets at least two and maybe even three
plate appearances before they go with
their best defense I'm talking to JP
Morosi from Fox and MLB Network here why
beyond the analytics we know JP that the
Red Sox are fantastic with two outs
right whether it's two outs and nobody
on or two outs and runners in scoring
position what's their explanation what
do they say when asked why they are so
good as situational hitters it's a great
question and I think it goes back to and
this year even more so than the past
years number one they're very well
prepared that they've got an excellent
coaching staff a new hitting coach this
year and Tim hires has got a lot of
credit for their their ability to vary
their approach and also the influence of
JD Martinez I think he has really had a
tangible effect on the rest of the
lineup in terms of their preparedness
their ability to be comfortable hitting
deep in counts I think that something JT
has always done for a long time and when
you see someone do it at that level with
that level of success as JD is doing it
right now
it has a very very manifestly positive
effect on the rest of the team I think
the Red Sox are living that right now
we're seeing a thoroughness of their
approach I think also the look at their
their lefties for the most part you look
at Ben and 10d great at-bats against
Kershaw in Game one and it just comes
from you've got great hitters who hang
in there really well left on left and
and there we go kind of the contrast
between the two teams
pennant nd left a young lefty hitter who
started against the lefty in Game one
had a sensational game Bellinger a an
LCS MVP on the other side didn't start
and it has only three at-bats I believe
in the whole series so it's a big
difference there the trust of the Red
Sox the gallic score the way he manages
them instill that confidence in them but
I
I would go back those two key new people
from this year Tim hires is the hitting
coach and then JD Martinez and the
influence that he has both when he's
batting and when the other guys are at
the plate as well we surprised when Ned
Colletti said the Dodgers JP were were
affected by the weather not not entirely
and here's what I mean by that I think
that you look at the the the early part
of the game and in Game one especially
the the aggressiveness of the Red Sox
there's certainly more used to the to
the elements and I realize this isn't
college football where it's it's in
Michigan playing USC and it's there's a
massive climate difference and all the
kids have grown up there and it's part
of the part of the DNA of those teams so
to speak you've got players from all
around the world on both teams here but
I think that you look at the way that
they're they're planning the Red Sox
comfort level at Fenway the angles of
the ballpark I think we saw that coming
to play David Freese was a little a
little tentative they're going after the
foul ball there was a ground rule double
that sort of fooled John Peterson I
would say maybe to amend a statement and
make it a little more comfortable for me
I would say the the elements and the
ballpark Fenway in October is a very
unique place and I do think the
atmosphere stepping in there you're cold
you may be not feeling quite as limber
as you normally do and I think by the
way that play the usual I believe for
Ryan Madson not being totally loose
wasn't throwing strikes obviously a huge
moment there in Game two curious to see
if Dave Roberts goes back to Ryan Madson
who curiously I believe still has a a
knee array of zero in the world series
despite the fact that all the inherited
runners have scored JP Morosi here from
MLB Network and from Fox all right I got
asked this and I'm asking not as an
Indians fan although people will not
believe that but I'll ask it regardless
ok JP is Major League Baseball relieved
that the Astros aren't playing this week
so it's a great question I think that
obviously the the back and forth
baseballs version of Spygate if you will
was not a good story for the league
clearly but it went
in like 36 hours yeah it did it did and
and I think with the Astros demise that
was part of it I think it would be
uncomfortable a little more
uncomfortable I guess if they were still
playing I would I would grant you that
it would be it'd be more of a topic MLB
they they had a very very quick
investigation they very quickly issued a
statement saying that they believed that
there was no nothing that was punishable
there from a standpoint of any game
sanctions or something dramatic of that
nature and and the Astros have
maintained publicly that there was
nothing of an offensive nature that it
was merely defensive which is really I
think it was really that was really
their sentiment it's very easy to put a
phone call into MLB's office and say
listen can you guys check into this
because that's the proper you know we're
not doing a citizen arrest here this is
you go to the authority on the matter
and let them let them handle things so
that that to me was a little a little
fishy gist of an argument to make from i
from my perspective but I think it's
something in general Andrew that's going
to be talked about a lot in the coming
weeks the GM meetings come up in about
10 days or so and MLB has got to sit
down and figure out candidly what kind
of sport they want to be from a
standpoint of technology it's it's
clearly the technology and that the fear
about signs being stolen not even just
the actual act of it but the fear of it
is changing the game because that's
that's what's building in so many of the
the pauses and they got to change my
signs here and there because you're
worried about signs being stolen that
that is a that is a very tangible
measurable fact it's lengthening the
games and and baseball has to find a way
to make a comprehensive solution in a
game where science dealing is as old as
the sport itself they have to find a way
to either regulate it or get everything
out in the open somehow someway because
until that happens we're gonna keep
seeing problems occur like we saw what
the Astros in this postseason real real
quick here there were plenty of reports
of skepticism from other teams about the
findings of MLB's investigation are you
hearing the same skepticism well I was a
report
passing there recently about the the
frustrations of other teams I think that
that's accurate and and I believe again
that's that to me will be a very
interesting forum to cover as the GM
meetings I would love to be actually in
there listen I won't be able to but
actually hear what that actually is said
because that that's going to be the area
of grievances I believe will be in those
meeting rooms and the Astros for a long
time Andrew have probably not been the
most popular team among other clubs so
that probably is part of the dynamic
here watch them tonight great stuff on
MLB tonight which is 213 by the way on
DirecTV on and they'll be Network and on
Fox of course as well John Ross you
follow them on Twitter with a Jo n no
wait John Merrow C JP Morosi thank you
sir likewise likewise thank you good to
connect with JP Morosi there the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience